[Music]
good morning Hank it's Friday April 20th
it occurred to me recently that
Brotherhood 2.0 is itself as a video
blog contributing to global warming
I want to make Brotherhood 2.0 a carbon
neutral video blog unfortunately Hank in
order to do that I'm going to have to
use a lot of arithmetic and as you well
know arithmetic is not my specialty
after all about two months ago I
calculated that each minute contained
100 seconds okay hey let's get started
getting carbon neutral
according to YouTube Brotherhood 2.0 has
received one hundred and sixteen
thousand four hundred and nineteen views
each video averages about three minutes
and nine seconds which is according to
my calculations one hundred and eighty
nine seconds so to start we're gonna
multiply one hundred sixteen thousand
four hundred nineteen times one hundred
and eighty nine which is of course eight
gajillion I know it's 22 million 3191
Wow people have spent 22 million 3191
seconds watching Brotherhood 2.0 we're
famous in a related story Americans need
more hobbies but it's not just the
amount of time people spend watching our
videos it's also the amount of time
people spend commenting on our videos
and talking about you know how much
cuter you are than me not that I'm
jealous but I have noticed that you
showed up on some blogs as one of the
five celebrities that certain people
would like to do certain things with
whereas I have you know not showed up on
those blogs but that's okay I mean you
know it's not a competition but you also
have to factor in the amount of time
that we spend making the videos so
according to my calculations the entire
brotherhood 2.0 project has taken up
twenty two million eight hundred fifty
six thousand three hundred ninety one
seconds of computer time that's six
thousand three hundred forty eight point
nine nine hours hank according to some
random website I just found the average
computer uses about 110 watts per hour
while browsing the Internet
so you multiply the number of hours
times 110 and you get six hundred ninety
eight thousand three hundred eighty nine
point seven but then in order to find
kilowatts we have to divide by a
thousand
698 point 4 kilowatts in the US the
average kilowatt takes about one point
three five pounds of carbon to create so
you multiply that 698 times one point
three five and then you find out that
our videoblog has personally led to 940
2.8 pounds of carbon emissions now I
know what you're saying Hank 942 pounds
that's not that much after all the
average American produces about 23,000
pounds of carbon but Hank that means
that Brotherhood 2.0 is about one
twenty-third of the average American and
Brotherhood 2.0 isn't even a person it's
an idea
let me put this into perspective for you
according to dimensions magazine there
have only been twenty-one people in all
of human history who weighed more than
Brotherhood 2.0 as carbon emissions hang
do you remember how I said in an earlier
video that Al Gore eats carbon emissions
and then poops them out and when he
poops them out they've been turned into
gold well if we get Al Gore all 942
pounds of brotherhood 2.0 is carbon
emissions and he ate it all and he
pooped it all out and it all came out
gold and it weighed the same coming out
as it did going in and then we stole the
money from Al Gore and then donated it
to Daniel misses campaign Daniel would
have ten million four hundred and twenty
nine thousand to eight hundred and
twenty four dollars that's the bad news
Hank but you know what the good news is
according to carbonfund.org in order to
offset our 942 pounds of carbon it's
going to cost us about two dollars and
seventy five cents yes geez at prices
like this lonely girl fifteen could go
carbon neutral so Hank I've donated our
two dollars and seventy five cents to
carbonfund.org making Brotherhood 2.0
through the month of April anyway carbon
neutral I'll see you on Monday Hank